covid cases in southern nevada  consistently dropping but we continue to  be one of just a handful of states  continuing the mass mandate local health  officials say everyone should continue  to follow the health protocols wearing a  mask washing hands getting tested  getting vaccinated last week the county  reporting its first case of ba.2 the new  sub-variant of omicron  cobit 19 testing remains central to our  overall mitigation strategy  operations at our search testing site at  texas station  has been extended until february 20th  the last day of operation for fiesta  henderson station site is today  health officials are also waiting on  deliveries of n95 mass which will be  available around the valley free of  charge also about two hundred thousand  covet tests expected to arrive in nevada  soon